willkommen zurück
ein spiel die wahrheit oder pflicht ohne
die wahrheit lottozahlen um zuzusehen
player spielen um geld und ruhm zu
gewinnen bist du roger oder player is
the water oder player ist roger oder
baywatch player
hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen heute zu einem neuen video
ich bin nämlich gerade zusammen mit max
an der nordsee und wir machen ja
wirklich sehr gern challenge videos und
wenn jetzt gedacht die bringen das mal
als nerd players auf ein komplett neues
level
nerf ist für diejenigen unter euch die
lassen nicht wissen ein kinofilm der am
8 9
rauskommen da geht es grundsätzlich
darum dass man ziemlich verrückt
entscheiden das macht was sie eigentlich
voll unser ding durch trichet eine
nachricht besorg dir einen katzen kostüm
und cs an
für 100 dollar wo soll ich jeden
katzenkopf die märkte gut herzen
köpfelte haben eine katze christi merkel
kann ihn ja natürlich der dollar sehr
gern eigentlich ja auch keiner passiert
erste challenge orchester führt also zu
ganzen hornhausen möchte kann
willst du scheiß wetter alter jugend c
wir haben es geschafft
ultra okay heute vielleicht noch eine
neue die haben es gerade macht
ach du heilige scheiße ich annehmen ja
okay da vorne ist immer da könnten wir
theoretisch ist hochverdient
ok drauf wetter alles geschafft ja
entspannt topleute ist luca
herrlich bestanden ich kriege auch nicht
challenge das rette deine katze mit der
hilfe von passanten akzeptieren
eine katze ist auf dem baum
ihr kriegt mich runter gelockt und
vielleicht muss sie jetzt mit keksen die
ein bisschen höher halten bisschen höher
halten
also ich will wegen gefahr bringt
da wird nicht gewählt dazu kommt mit
wasserpistolen mir wurde gerade
angeraten meine katze dies da oben mit
einer waffe zu erschießen komm runter
oder wie schießen geht noch weiter
zurück geht noch weiter zurück er hat
nur noch hinter dem
jungs ihr habt wahrscheinlich schon
gesehen was hier abgeht meine katze
sachen komplett aus und ich habe keine
ahnung wie wir kriege not katze also
wirklich hab ich bin im fluss er ist aus
der hand oder so du kannst auch der
anfang an hätten sie runter mit katzen
aus max hat und welche menschen machen
wir gleich mit dreck katze kennst du
dich mit katzen auf ein einlenken kannst
du nicht kannst du probieren
bei king.com
so leute wir suchen jetzt mal lud weil
es mir gerade abgehauen und wir sind
hier im park das ist eine seiner
bevorzugten ecken der park hier und ich
gucke mal ob es irgendwie auf einem baum
verkrochen hat oder so und dann kann ich
endlich meinen of change abschließend
wie meine belohnung holen ok wo ist da
größer
bisher kein blut hinsicht los
das war nicht mit dem wasser vorhin
wirklich nicht bitte komm runter nein
ich schaff's allein nämlich leute auch
wieder hilfe also ich suche mir als
hilfe leute da vorne sehe ich jemanden
meine katze ist auf dem baum
jugendliche stellen gut mit katzen oder
du kannst einfach mal vielleicht
hingehen und ein gutes wort einlegen und
seine nutzer ist die katze zur los komm
runter
bitte sehr junge mann würde gerne ein
mit dem mit ihr reden wir jetzt einfach
mal soll ich bitte sie es geschafft alle
drei stellen will
danke dir noch mal dass mir so leicht
gemacht hat ein bisschen für mich selber
was auch schwierig an einem baum
herunter zu kommen aber ich habe es ja
schon echt schwer gemacht
ich habe auf jeden fall aber egal wir
haben heute drei challenges geschafft
das nächste challenge video kommt bei
max auf dem kanal ist es unten verlinkt
und was auch unten verlinkt ist es eine
twitter umfrage wo er zwischen zwei
auswahlmöglichkeiten entscheiden können
was wir im nächsten video machen sollen
das heißt es auf jeden fall mal umsonst
was ist jetzt ein video das was jetzt
ihr vom video meine damen und herren
wenn ihr noch nicht genug kriegen können
von challenges findet ihr hier einmal
das video von kelly verlinkt und am 24
08 kommt auch noch hier verlinkt das
video von k s freak sonst würd ich sagen
der kinofilm trailers in der
beschreibung verlinkt wenn es euch
gefallen hat letzten leica und wir
im nächsten video wieder job